voilà alors ça chauffe rend encore plus
mardi prochain veille des sports la
ligue doit d'un mot ou est-ce que vous
pouvez nous rappeler cette pour des
enfants de la terre bien nous avons des
maisons qui sont des maisons de
l'urgence des maisons dans lesquelles
elles ne recevront des enfants qui nous
sont envoyées par le ministère de la
justice ou par différents hôpitaux et
dans ces maisons il ya des gosses qui
viennent pendant une durée illimitée
alors ça peut venir ça peut être une
semaine ça peut être six mois le temps
qu'on organise leur quotidien et voilà
pour que ces maisons continuent à
exister pour qu'on puisse en avoir
d'autres mâcon bien que le monde va nous
appeler en misant tendresse et païenne
nous et on en a trois pour l'instant et
ces maisons ne coûte 500 mille francs
par an donc on fait des concerts des
matches de tennis et le concert de mardi
est notre gros concert c'est le concert
qui est le plus important pour
l'association
voilà donc donc tous les to les font
toutes les recettes iront bien
évidemment pour la construction et
l'entretien de ces mises en tendresse et
puis vous avez également une action
l'étranger au tchad en roumanie ou
encore au liban
oui on a différentes opérations que je
ferai avec certains orphelinats dans
notre pays ce sont des dispensaires et
puis quelquefois des envois de dons de
médicaments ou de freins ou deux enfants
naissaient de participer quoi mais pour
l'instant notre priorité c'est en france
et met en tendresse ce sont les maisons
qui sont les plus proches de nous il ya
cette urgence et en ce qui concerne
cette opération de mardi donc au palais
des sports mais c'est tout l'argent ira
directement pour une maison d'amour ou
yannick noah vous je sais bien que vous
n'êtes pas venu pour cela mais un mode
du tennis français qui semble un petit
peu malade à une semaine de roland
garros à part santoro qui tente en fait
très belles étincelles
on semble que même au fond du gouffre il
ya un passage un peu difficile il ya
moins de résultats que par le passé mais
je crois que
partie demandé à de tels résultats on
peut que progresser on essaie de
travailler c'est de travailler dans le
bon sens fabrice a fait de bons matches
as roma semaine dernière j'espère que ça
va continuer comme ça en tout cas c'est
une bonne source d'émulation il ya
roland garros qui arrive tout le monde
est en train de travailler il ya des
stages un peu partout que ce soit à
roland garros même avec moi et j'espère
que ça va bien se passer en tout cas on
y croit tous merci héninois donc rendez
vous à tous ce mardi soir au palais des
sports merci à connaissez vous